I'm here to say to you tonight our state
of the state is growing stronger every
day
Governor Joe Lombardo laying out his
vision for the future we must remain
dedicated to the twin propositions of
saving for and guarding against
the next unexpected event that shakes
our economy and rattles our livelihoods
the hour-long address a pitch to
lawmakers and the people of Nevada about
moving forward out of the pandemic while
saving for the next emergency Lombardo
says his budget won't raise taxes but
instead makes Nevada even more
attractive for businesses unlocking
Innovation and investments in logistics
entertainment science and technology or
embracing entrepreneurship the message
is that Nevada is ready to partner the
big topic of the night education the
governor says he wants to increase per
student spending by two thousand dollars
provide scholarships to keep teachers in
Nevada and offer parents the option of
choosing a non-public school set aside
politics and turf guarding to deal with
the stubborn facts regarding public
education in Nevada
nevadics public schools have been
historically underfunded and have
historically underperformed for our
children Lombardo also proposed pausing
the state's gas tax for a year giving
state employees raises and immediate
bonuses and creating new laws to hold
career criminals accountable introducing
legislation that makes it harder not
easier to commit a crime in the state of
Nevada
the governor wants to grow the rainy day
fund while creating a new segment of
money for a bipartisan committee to
spend on major infrastructure and
capital projects let's plant the trees
that some of us may never see